hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
and of course no man is an island no one
can do this themselves you started this
by saying check this out Choppers like
you're gonna lay something amazing on us
and that was it oh before I went on Mike
I said check this out Choppers my
favorite thing is to say check this out
and then do a very mundane thing I think
it's I've it's always made me laugh to
be like walking up to an elevator and
turn to someone I don't even know and go
check this out and then hit the down
button
it uh it amuses me to no end probably
nobody else nobody else
um
but I am excited you're both with me as
I always am I know this is nice son of
obsession Matt Gourley good to have you
guys uh here nice to be here there is
something I want to bring up today okay
and that is that
[Music]
um
the good news is I think people listen
to the podcast because
I've had a bunch of friends reach out to
me more than one I'd say it's three
friends have reached out to me
independently of each other and they've
said
I have a good doctor who could help you
with your hearing loss and I didn't know
what they were talking about and then I
remembered we did the uh shows in New
York and you remember there was a q a at
the end and a young a young man stood up
yeah
who's I think from Brooklyn if I
remember correctly yeah and he said uh I
asked him what he did and he said that
he
um is someone who checks for hearing
loss and I said oh I should get checked
out I should come and it was all
you know we weren't we were kind of
joking around but I just was making
conversation and I've had a bunch of
people reach out and say you need to get
your uh I have a good doctor for you
because I realize that you're struggling
with this hearing loss and it's not true
I mean I don't know that I am I don't
think that I am but I realized that it
was a good way to get sympathy
oh the story took a weird turn well I
just realized that all I have to do on
the podcast
is come up with some kind of malady and
then a lot of loving comes my way no now
you're gonna get friends texting you
going I know a good therapist for you
you're sociopath wait so what's wrong
with you now you monster yeah what's
wrong with you now my nipples oh my
nipples are three times the size they
used to be your nipples not your areolas
well don't can't we just call them
nipples
yeah Ariel is the pepperoni the nipple
is the little piece of kibble yeah okay
the areola it grew correct they grew
much larger they're the size uh of
Hubcaps now you're so they overlap it's
like a MasterCard look like a Venn
diagram it's a Venn diagram
there's one is happiness the other's
misery and then when they come together
is bliss and that's your sternum right
there that's my sternum yeah I've got
crazily enlarged I'm just going to put
that out there because I want to start I
don't even know who treats that but I
want to see I want to no I want to see
which listeners say oh I'm so worried
about Conan's okay crazily enlarged uh
hubcap areolas
you know we'll find out and then they'll
because what I got from the um
uh from my friends and from other people
that didn't even really know that well
they were saying oh this doctor that
doctor there's a special kind of hearing
aid you should use and I thought wow
this is we were just I'm just making
conversation with that young man I was
gonna say do you really think you don't
need it what do you mean what was it you
were around me a lot maybe you do my
wife is always uh getting annoyed that I
can't hear her but that could be just me
tuning out my partner of 21 years yeah I
could be because I can't hear that yaket
anymore
to the Moon Alice straight to the Moon
uh so who knows but
um maybe I do have to get it checked out
you never know like what if you put on
in a hearing aid and you're like oh my
God new world I could hear amazing what
if I put I got a really good hearing aid
and I put it in and I'm walking around
and and I just suddenly started to hear
that guy's an don't worry I
can't hear it yeah
don't worry okay and I just start to
hear all this guy peaked in 98 yeah
but it's you saying it
yeah his best friend was on The Simpsons
talk show was a queen that's all I hear
you get superhero hearing abilities yeah
but all I'm but all I'm hearing is my
own negative inner voices he thinks the
podcast goes out never goes out yeah
electronic Castle is just something that
they're keeping them busy
I hear that guy has giant slap Jacks for
nipples Venn diagram just like the
MasterCard logo that that's all I'm
hearing they should they should make a
hearing aid that turns up your inner
voice
yeah yeah I get enough of me I don't
really hear me you seem like a very
emotionally healthy person oh no you are
no why do I think I hide it
I think you're what do you think Sona I
think that's a I thought you were yeah I
thought I think you're on an even Keel I
really don't know I'm more in League
with like how you are I I haven't is
that bad well maybe not that bad okay
yeah let's not get crazy here no he's
true you were just like uh I've got the
same problems as that guy and you're
just from just Son of Sam
I'm a little like that guy you Son of
Sam
oh I guess maybe not no I just sometimes
get a little cranky I'm more like nephew
of Sam yeah yeah
um I I don't see that with you I well I
you know I got all my shares of anxiety
too I I carry it with me like you do but
really you know I check it at the door
because I'm a professional you don't
just blather on about it a couple of
freaks yeah
sorry I didn't mean that you know I care
about you too no you don't no kidding I
do I do I love you both I do I care
about you guys yeah yeah and I want you
both to feel good because we helped you
get a new kitchen that's right what
that's all you said why are you bring it
in my kitchen because right before the
podcast you were telling us look at the
new kitchen I got and I thought yeah but
I know it helped pay for that yeah job
exactly yakking on the podcast Which is
my job it's not a job you're here
because you love us
which is it which is it can it be which
is it no I want it to be both book aside
pick one money
sorry I just did it without thinking I
mean I love you guys but the money keeps
me coming back I'm here because I'm a
podcast artist I want all my money to
charity I do this for the Love of the
Game you know what you know what I would
say you're not a podcaster you're a pod
crafter you are a true Artisan my
anxiety level's a Pete you're a true
Artisan of this form so let's get back
to me okay uh which is um just putting
it out there uh rapid hearing loss and
uh areolas imagine you took all the
batter and made one pancake
right and then right and then uh put the
whole pan it's the whole pan and then uh
you put you just dropped a little
Chiclet in the center yeah that's what
we're dealing with here it's as if Dolly
Parton was wearing a kind of bespeckled
salmon colored bra and you just took
that bra and flattened it out over your
chest oh you made Dolly Parton's boobs
unlikable that's impossible it is
impossible
compared them to variolas I'm and I love
her boobs and you guys you made it bad
no I don't think you're crazy yeah uh
anyway uh I do appreciate the kind words
uh I do think my hearing is fine yeah so
Friends of the show reach out with your
nipple doctors so cool even handles that
I don't know who that is there's ear
nose nose and throat a gynecologist no
no no there's nipples pits and bits
npbs I'm an mpb what do you sir what
kind of doctor I'm an MPP what nipples
pits and bits